with the covert situation in london now
declared a major incident
concern like the virus itself is
spreading
government advisers are suggesting that
the current rate of infection
could be as high as 150 000 new cases
every day it's putting a huge amount of
pressure on the nhs
there are more patients than we've ever
had we've had
less staff than we've ever had and it's
not just the intensive care units
the hospital the wards run by our
respiratory physician colleagues our
geriatricians
everywhere is full beyond bursting start
breaking themselves to make this place
make this happen and to keep our
patients safe and it's not
going to be enough when 34 million
people moved into tier 3 on december the
16th
there were over 15 000 covid patients in
hospital beds in england
that number had risen to 17701 by
christmas day
it's now over 29 000.
we're now in our third period of
lockdown and in the past
these tougher restrictions have shown to
reduce the number of covid19 infections
the concern is that it takes at least
two weeks for any impact
to be seen because of the incubation
period of the virus itself
so of course the nhs are worried that
they need to get through the next week
or ten days
at least before the benefits of this
lockdown will hit the wards
in sheffield as they are across the
country health experts are hoping the
rollout of vaccinations will also
soon begin to ease the pressure not just
to prevent more virus-related deaths
but to allow non-covered patients to get
the life-saving treatments
that they need in the spring we noticed
that people were not coming to hospital
and we
need to make sure that all everybody's
health care needs are considered this
time it isn't just about covert it's
about everybody else who needs to access
the nhs
in response to the current situation a
government spokesperson has told sky
news
our nhs is facing a huge challenge and
we continue to support it in every
possible way
it's absolutely paramount people in
london and the rest of the country
follow the rules and stay at home to
protect the nhs
and save lives winter provides the
perfect storm for the nhs
as rising infections are exacerbated by
the flu season
but the combination of lockdown
restrictions and the vaccination program
provides some light at the end of the
tunnel the hope is
that the tunnel will be a short one
fraser moored
sky news sheffield